هذا ما تبقى من الوجود الأمريكي
في الكثير من أفغانستان
، الهياكل العظمية المجوفة للقواعد العسكرية المترامية الأطراف
الآن تحت سيطرة طالبان
بمجرد وجود المئات منا وقوات الناتو
في فوب أندار في مقاطعة غزني ،
وترك آخر الأمريكيين اثنين من
منذ سنوات ، لكن ذاكرتهم لا تزال كامنة
مثل الأشباح ، من الغريب جدًا أن ترى
هذا ، فأنت تعلم
أن طالبان منحت حق الوصول إلى CNN جنبًا إلى جنب
مع المخرج الأفغاني الحائز على جوائز
نجيب الله قريشي
حريصًا على استعراض غنائم الحرب ،
لذا فنحن نصل إلى آخر.
قاعدة لنا وبالفعل أستطيع أن أرى عددًا كبيرًا
من المركبات العسكرية هناك
وفقًا لقوات طالبان الأفغانية
هنا وقد استسلمت قبل ثلاثة أسابيع عندما
نفد طعامهم
تاركًا الأسلحة والذخيرة وأكثر
عندما كان الأمريكيون هنا
كنت أنت ورجالك يهاجمون هذه القاعدة  الكثير من
القلق يا عزيزي
نعم لقد هاجمنا هذه القاعدة مرات عديدة
عندما كانت أمريكا هنا ،
أجرينا عمليات
كنا نستخدمها
، وكان لدى الأمريكيين طائرات الهليكوبتر الخاصة بهم.
دبابات ودبابات على الأرض
قاومناها نحن المجاهدون جيدًا
الآن يتجولون عبر ما تبقى من
مركز العمليات التكتيكية
سيتم تجريد أي شيء ذي قيمة
وبيعه أثناء
السير عبر ما تبقى
من هذه القواعد الأمريكية ، عليك أن تسأل
نفسك
ما الذي كان كل شيء
لأمريكا  تجربة رائعة مع
بناء الأمة الآن اختفت في الغبار
، نعتقد أنه في يوم من الأيام
سينتصر المجاهدون وأن القانون الإسلامي
لن يأتي إلى أفغانستان فقط ولكن في جميع
أنحاء العالم
لسنا في عجلة من أمرنا نعتقد أنه
سيأتي يومًا ما
لن ينتهي الجهاد  حتى اليوم الأخير ،
كان اعترافًا مخيفًا من مجموعة
تدعي أنها تريد السلام على الرغم من
استمرار الهجوم الدموي
منذ أن بدأت الولايات المتحدة انسحابها في
مايو ، تقدم المسلحون في جميع
أنحاء البلاد بمعدل ينذر بالخطر على
ظهر شاحنات البيك أب الأمريكية
في غزني.  طريق سريع نمر بقاعدة تلو الأخرى
ترفع جميعها علم المسلحين
في نهاية بازارنا إنه موقع مشابه
في أيام التمرد السري
انتهت وطالبان تستعد
لإعادة تأسيس الإمارة
التي أتت الولايات المتحدة لتدميرها ،
لكن حاكم طالبان مولوي كامل
يصر على أن المجموعة قد تغيرت منذ ذلك
الحين والفرق بين طالبان وطالبان
هو أن طالبان عام 2001 كانت
جديدة والآن هذا  طالبان تتمتع بخبرة
منضبطة ، وأن
أنشطتنا تسير على ما يرام ، فنحن
نطيع
قادتنا ، ويشعر الكثير من الناس بالقلق من أنه
إذا تولى طالبان السلطة مرة أخرى ،
فإن حقوق المرأة ستتراجع إلى الوراء ،
كيف يمكنك ضمان حماية حقوق المرأة
[موسيقى]
نؤكد ذلك للناس  في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، وخاصة شعب
أفغانستان
، أعطى الإسلام حقوقًا للجميع على
قدم المساواة ، فالمرأة لها حقوقها الخاصة.
الفتيات الصغيرات لكن معلمهن يقول
إنهن سيتلقين
التعليم الديني فقط ولن يذهبن إلى المدرسة العادية
في الليل  انفصلت عن زملائي الذكور
وأنام في الجزء المخصص للسيدات
من المنزل مع الأطفال.
لقد تحدثت إلى بعض النساء
في هذه الغرفة ووعدت أنني
لن أظهر أيًا من وجوههن ، لكن
هذا مثير للاهتمام لأنك تعلم
يتحدث الطالبان كثيرًا عن كيف
تغير الأمر ويمكن للفتيات الذهاب إلى المدرسة الآن
ولكني سألت إذا كانت أي من هؤلاء الفتيات
ستذهب إلى المدرسة وقيل لي
أن
الفتيات لا يذهبن إلى المدرسة على الإطلاق وعندما قلت
لماذا لا  فتيات يذهبن إلى المدرسة قالوا إن
طالبان تقول إنه أمر سيء
هنا ما يقوله طالبان يذهب
هذا الآن ما يبدو عليه مستقبل أفغانستان
بعيدًا عما تصوره الولايات
المتحدة وما كان يحلم به الكثير من الأفغان
بينما يمضي طالبان
نحو انتصار
شبه مؤكد كلاريسا  وارد سي ان غازني محافظة افغانستان